hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going to be going over one
of if not my favorite and most
definitely flashiest arc in kamitsu no
yuba's story this is the entire
entertainment district arc from the one
and only demon slayer but quickly two
seconds before we get into the video if
you do enjoy my content and want to
watch more stuff just like this then be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people plus extra long
videos like these take even longer to
produce so i really do appreciate it but
anyway enough of that let's get into the
flashiest arc in all of demon slayer
so four months after the mugen train
incident and the passing of rengoku all
three boys had been relentlessly
training at the butterfly mansion and
occasionally going on missions so that
they could improve their strength
tangido says that they're able to endure
all of their training since the boys are
together later after completing one of
his solo missions tanjuro approaches the
butterfly mansion to hear the screams of
the young girls inside inside the
property aoi and naho scream to be let
go after the sound hashira tengan uzoi
picked them up and started to take them
away while the other girls in their plea
for their freedom aoe calls out to kano
to try and help save them initially
hesitant on what to do kanel makes the
decision to chase after uzoi and she
grabs a hold of the girls tengan looks
at kano and tells her to obey her orders
but when she doesn't respond to him he
becomes aggravated and starts to call
her a stuck-up pig the other girls get
scared by his screaming but they all
managed to master up their courage to
swarm him and stop him from kidnapping
aoe and naho at this point tanjuro
enters the property and although he
initially gets confused as to what's
going on he decides to head butt tengen
in order to free the girls however as he
goes to make contact dengan escapes the
head bar flying above them and revealing
that he previously used to be a ninja
tanjiro angrily demands that uzui
returns the girls wakiyo and sumi
continuously assault him with names
because of this tengen becomes even more
riled up at their disrespect and he
demands that they obey him as their
superior officer however tangero
stubbornly refuses to acknowledge tengen
as his superior causing him to explode
with anger while seeing him with anger
tengan explains that he needs female
corpse members in order to carry out his
mission he then states that since they
aren't sukuco he doesn't need to ask
shinobu for permission to take the girls
keo cries out that naho isn't a corpse
member so tengen just tosses her off the
roof and decides to only take aoi still
not pleased with the outcome tangero
demands that he gives up aoi and instead
he will go in her place
and with almost perfect timing senetsu
and inosuke arrive to help protect the
girls also offering to go on the mission
in place of them uzui ends up giving in
and whacks aoe on the back as he returns
it to the girls as the boys set off on
the mission they asked tengan where
exactly they are going to which he says
the flashiest place in japan stepped in
lust and ever ice ultimately revealing
that they are heading towards the one
and only entertainment district
before arriving outside the
entertainment district tengen begins
instructing the trio and establishes
himself as the leader of the three young
demon slayers he then specifically
states his status as a god and demands
that they all bow scrape and evert their
eyes being genuinely intrigued tanjo
falls for the tengan's flamboyance and
asks what it is that uzuwi rules over as
a so-called god sensing the complete
absurdity of this scenario zenitsu
concludes that uzui is a bad sign and is
left speechless by just how gullible
tanjiro truly is tengen explains that he
is the god of festivals and upon hearing
this inosuki loudly introduces himself
as the god of the mountain trying to
imply that they are both on equal ground
but this disgusts uzui he then instructs
the group to follow him to a wisteria
house there they will discuss their
plans then in almost an instant he
sprints off and vanishes leaving the
group to chase after him in a complete
panic once they arrive at the wisteria
house tengan asks the group to be on a
lookout for a young lady he could marry
which infuriates zenitsu he angrily
tells tengen to stop screwing around and
stop using members of the corpse to be
his matchmakers tengan blows up and
yells that he doesn't need a matchmaker
since he's already married and that
they're searching for his wives who have
failed to respond to his letters zenitsu
who doesn't believe it tells tenkan to
stop spreading his fantasies causing
tenkin to angrily whack him in the face
with a pile of letters tanjuro begins to
sift through all of the letters noticing
the large quantity he comments that she
must have been a fast writer to which
tenkan clarifies that the large quantity
is due to the fact that he has three
wives after hearing this zenitsu's head
erupts and fills with rage thinking that
the tenkan is lying he demands to know
how he could possibly have three wives
tenkin gets angry at his remarks and
punches zenitsu in his stomach with such
force that it renders him completely
unconscious tangible begins to ask how
they plan on sneaking into the district
leaving their tengan to explain that
they will be disguised his wives
whichakunuichi were originally stationed
there after he himself failed to find
any leads as a customer but after they
narrowed down a few possible locations
of where the demon might be they lost
all communication overhearing the
situation anoski bruntly asks what if
his wives are already dead to which
tengan also punches them in the stomach
knocking him unconscious as well within
the entertainment district a majority of
the workers are individuals who were
sold into the business due to poverty
and deaths as a courtesan their job is
to appeal and entertain customers so
they can eventually find a wealthy man
who is willing to buy their freedom the
highest classification of a courtesan is
an orion who is considered to be the
most artistic beautiful and educated and
is thus only ever reserved for the
wealthiest of customers as the group
finally arrives tengan uses his charming
looks to give away the boys who were
disguised as girls and is initially
successfully able to give tanjido away
to their takito house thinking then
proceeds down the street with the other
two boys following behind anosuke and
uzoi notice a courtesan procession
coming towards them on this tree and
learned that the aurian named konowatsu
is on her way to greet asuto zenitsu
notices the orion and angrily yells
tengan demanding to know if that's his
wife as well which ends up earning him
another punch in the face a woman
approaches tengen and asks him if he is
looking for a house and offers to take
inosuke into the ogimoto house to which
tengen accepts standing there alone
zinetsu fearfully starts to realize that
he is the only one left with the hashira
skipping over to the ogimoto house where
two women are clapping for joy at just
how beautiful enosuke is after removing
her makeup due to this they become
motivated to educate him and transform
him to become the most popular orion
within the district
meanwhile in the kyogoku house zenitsu
is in the middle of putting on an
emotional performance with a shamasian
after being abandoned by tengan uzui and
at the tokito house tangido is assisting
in doing household chores the staff asks
tanjiro to carry the orion's belongings
up to her room which he does so happily
when he arrives at the room he discovers
two young girls gossiping inside and
overhears them talking about ashanuke
confused tanjiro asks what it is the
girls explain that ashinoke is when a
courtesan runs off with a customer
without paying off their debts they also
mention a rumor that suma the most
recent courtesan had run away which
catches tanjiru's attention just then
koenatsu walks into the room and tells
the girls to stop gossiping and thanks
tanjuro for carrying up her belongings
she gives him a piece of candy to
express her gratitude and tanjiru
decides to ask her if the rumor
regarding soma was true or not koenigsu
looks stunned by the sudden question and
asks him why exactly he's asking her
tangido panics and lies telling her that
suma is his older sister but due to
sanjido being unable to lie he pulls a
sour face and ends up frightening all of
the girls koenatsu again questions
tanjido if he was sold into the house
just like his sister causing him to
again uncomfortably lie that he was in
fact sold and was exchanging letters
with suma koinatu reluctantly tells
tangido that she does not believe suma
would run away however when they
discovered her diary in her desk she had
written that she was planning on running
away she also reveals that there has
been no information regarding if she
hasn't managed to escape or not tanjiru
begins to speculate that it could be the
demon that was creating the facade that
sumer had run away and might possibly be
responsible for implanting the diary he
then prays for her safety and promises
to himself that he will find a way to
help her at a similar time in the
district tengen is seen on the top of a
roof watching the activity of the public
he fails to notice any unusual activity
and can't help but have a bad feeling on
the lack of action and proceeds to
speculate that the demon must be strong
due to its ability to hide its presence
back at the okimoto house enosuke is
starting to investigate the whereabouts
of makio and overhears two women
conversing in front of makio's room
the woman begins to gossip that makio
was feeling unwell and had not left her
room for the entire day anosuke begins
to speculate on the information and
proceeds down the hall however he
becomes infuriated at having to wear the
uncomfortable kinemon during the hot
weather and recalls tengan's threats
before the boys had separated tenkin had
threatened him not to strip down or
speak due to his deep voice making it
harder for inosuke to gather information
inside makio's room an ominous voice is
seen questioning a woman who she was
sending letters to a large obi-like
demon is then seen holding the woman
hostage the demon calls the woman by her
name revealing the hostage to be makio
while being held hostage by the ob demon
makio tries to formulate a plan to try
to escape however the demon senses
inosuke snooping in the hallway and
decides to make an escape itself inosuke
senses the change in the atmosphere and
rushes into the room he discovers the
room is destroyed and senses the demon
is hiding in the ceiling as the demon
tries to escape inosuke begins to give
chase and rushes down the hallway as he
prepares to turn down the hallway he
decides to punch a hole in the wall in
order to pull the demon out however when
he swings a customer comes into the
clearing and unknowingly gets punched
into the wall the staff look in horror
as zanowski looks around to try and find
the demon but to his frustration he
loses size of it and blames the customer
over at the kyogoku house zinetsu calms
down after his emotional performance and
begins to search for hinatsuru due to
the fact that the staff had been
mourning the manager's death he's had
trouble collecting any information on
her possible whereabouts so far
susanetsu decides to use his advanced
sense of hearing in order to listen to
try and find any information on what's
going on in doing so he overhears a girl
quietly sobbing and rushes to try and
find her when he arrives he discovers
the room is completely destroyed and the
girl is disheveled in the middle of it
he approaches her but she begins to sob
again causing zinitsu to frantically try
to comfort her as he's kneeling on the
ground zenitsu suddenly gets chills and
sends the sunning approach from behind
him the orion of the house warabahime
glares down at him and coldly demands
what business he has in her room without
turning around zinetsu recognizes the
sound that she is giving off is not
human and realizes that she is the demon
that the four slayers have been
searching for wada bahime angrily
repeats her question after zinezu fails
to respond and the other girls of the
house explain that zenitsu is news of
the house zenitsu attempts to apologize
and explain that he was checking on the
girl but this angers wadahime who rudely
calls in itsu ugly and creepy leaving
him shocked wadahime looks around to see
that the room is still in a mess and
pulls the girl who was crying by the air
causing her to yell in pain
the girl apologizes for failing to clean
the room but wada bahime continues to
harm the girl causing her to yell out in
agony unable to put up with the abuse
zenitsu grabs whatever he may by the arm
demanding that she let go of the girl
skipping back two nights before the
demon slayers arrived at the
entertainment district the manager of
the kyogoku house omitsu holds a meeting
with the orion of her household she
explains to wada boheme that she has to
restrain herself from bullying the other
courtesans of the house to which wada
bahime feigns her innocence amitsu
expresses her frustration at having
ignored her behaviour explaining that
she has gone too far but wada boheme
guilts her by mentioning that she brings
money into the household omitsu becomes
nervous as she mentions a tale she heard
from an elder when she was just a child
she explains that the elder had recalled
a courtesan who was extremely beautiful
but had a rotten personality the
courtesan was the orient of their
household and had been around since the
elder was a child and was eerily similar
to the ori and the elder saw when she
was an adult coincidentally the orien's
names both ended in heimei and had a
nasty glare when they were both
displeased as omitsu continues talking
she notices the similarities between the
elders description and wada beheme
however before she questions the
fidelity of her race wada bahime
transforms into her original appearance
as and pulls omitsu from the house
as they fly up into the night sky
eerily remarks that the people around
her had managed to survive by remaining
silent on the atrocities that they've
witnessed until tonight omitsu fearfully
brandishes a knife revealing her
intention to kill daki however she
berates omitsu for being more stupid
than she believed and bids her goodbye
dropping her to her death daki
nonchalantly lands on a nearby rooftop
and struts away as the citizens discover
omitsu dead on the ground
when she returns to her room daki
discovers muzan awaiting and humbly
greets him
muzan comments on her appearance and
speculates that she's eating a large
amount of humans he proudly
congratulates her and cautions her to
not act recklessly complies and
receives information regarding the
possible arrival of the demon slayers
she is encouraged by muzan to become
even stronger and crueler than she was
before the flashback ends and rolls into
the situation with zinitsu confronting
whatabahime she becomes angry and slams
him into the wall rendering him
completely unconscious she openly voices
her disgust and demands that he never
touch her again and also scarily remarks
that she will administer harshu
discipline the commotion causes amitsu's
husband to rush over and apologize for
zenko's actions he begs her to forgive
him as they prepare for the customers
suddenly wada bahime has a sudden change
of character and apologizes to the
manager while he quickly orders for her
room to be cleaned as watabahime leaves
the room she has her doubts about
zinetsu and realizes that he isn't any
ordinary human and might actually be a
member of the demon slayers in her clean
room she can be seen ominously laughing
to herself as she openly welcomes the
idea of demon slayers arriving in the
district promising she'll eat all of
them
outside tangier waits looking into the
night sky feeling uneasy as he comments
on the dark and musky smell that has
taken the town
with the manager being informed of
zenko's sudden disappearance from the
kyogoku house the staff member explains
to him that she had disappeared after
being left to rest in her room however
the mention of zenko angers the manager
and he tells the staff member to forget
all about zenko the manager chases her
out before expressing his frustration at
having to submit to wada bahime's
desires elsewhere on the rooftop inosuke
can be seen explaining the demon he saw
in the ogimoto house tanjuro his exotic
description and excitement worries
tajiro and he tells him to calm down
until tengen and zenitsu arrive for the
meeting tenkan stealthily and flashily
arrives undetected and proclaims that
sinitsu will not be arriving he also
mentions that he might have put the boys
in immediate danger tenkan tells inosuke
and tanjiro that they must leave the
district before the upper ranked demon
makes their move and announces that he
will be continuing the mission alone
tangero tries to argue against his
decision however tengen quickly leaves
as fast as he arrived tanju begins to
wonder if they are trustworthy due to
being members of the lowest demon slayer
rank but inosuka interrupts to inform
them that they've climbed their ranks a
fair birth and he flexes his hand out
and shows tanjido the kano rank which
appears and tells them their status in
the ranking confused about the
revelation inosuke explains to tanchito
they're following the final selections
their hands were marked with the
wisteria flower and grey theme tangero
is left slightly embarrassed and not
knowing how to check but anoscape
promptly tells him to cheer up tangero
gets back on track and tells inosuke
that he will meet with him outside the
ogimoto house once night falls claiming
that he wants to finish investigating
the tokito house before he leaves which
angers inosuke he punches tajiro by the
cheek and tells him to follow him at
that moment but tanju explains that
there might be a secret passage beneath
the household that might lead to the
demon he tells inosuke that he thinks
the tengen's wives are still alive as
well as zenitsu and he asks him to
comply in order to save them
successfully anosuke smiles and lets
tanjuno know that he was thinking the
exact same thing and agrees to the plan
back at the tokiso house koenatsu has
finished with her preparations and is
visited by tanjuro he arrives without
his disguise and informs koenatsu that
he is leaving the house and asks her to
pass on his payment for his meals he's
had she asks why he's dressed that way
and tanjudo explains that he's actually
a boy while apologizing to her but to
her this was no surprise as she claims
that she knew all along and wondered
what he was up to he tells her that he
hopes to save the individuals who have
disappeared from the house and she
expresses her relief while also saying
that she'll be leaving as well they wish
each other well and say their goodbyes
before tanjulo leaves the room but when
koenatsu hears a sound she turns around
to discover standing right behind
her as tanjoro hurries off he catches
the faint smell of the upper ranked
demon at the okamoto house enosuke can
be seen complaining as he waits for
tanjiro to arrive
since the time to meet was long overdue
onoski became fed up and decides to
begin the mission alone he jumps with
such force that he bursts through the
ceiling and calls for the mice to bring
his swords these mice are team
conservants who had been especially
trained to act on missions as an oscar
begins to change and make his leave a
member of the staff can be seen with a
horrified expression as she sees anosuke
with a boar's mask over at the kyogoku
house omitsu's husband is seen holding a
kimono in his hand in just a moment
tengan appears in the room and holds a
kunai to his throat demanding to know
the whereabouts of hinatsuru and zenko
the man quickly reveals that zenko had
suddenly disappeared and that hinatsuru
was sick therefore she went to a low end
brothel tengan questions the man further
and asks who he thinks is responsible
for causing the trouble within the house
however the man begins to hyperventilate
but tengan reassures him that he can be
trusted and he will exact revenge on the
individual responsible the man envisions
his deceased wife and informs tengen
that it's wada bahime who's causing the
problems he also informs him that she
has the north room where the sunlight
never falls
the man stops talking for a moment and
quickly turns around however by that
point tengan had already left the man is
left alone in the room holding his
wife's bloody kimono when the tengan
arrives to watahime's room he discovers
that the demon is not there and she is
probably out hunting he quickly leaves
the search for hinatsuru and swears that
he will return to defeat the demon with
his own hands elsewhere tangido has
discovered within kawanatu's room
as she attempts to kidnap her within her
obi daki informs tanjiro that she will
not be eating him since he is dirty and
old meaning that only a hashera will
suffice her appetite tangero yells at
her to release koenatsu however his
demands irritate as she lashes
out throwing him from the building
tangido is left stunned from her immense
speed and power but he manages to regain
his composure and stands back up on his
feet he begins to analyze the situation
and realizes that her obi has a special
power that can swallow people whole at
that moment climbs out of the
window and is amazed that tangier was
still alive tanju apologizes to nezuko
after realising that one of the shoulder
straps is broken on the box he tells her
that he has to leave her here for now
and warns her not to come out of the box
unless her life is in utter danger he
initiates his attack against daki by
using his water-breathing fourth form
striking tide turbulent to attempt to
slash atu obi he successfully manages to
perform an aerial attack against daki
and slices the end of the ob that was
holding koinatu captive dhaki states
that tanjido is cute but he makes her
sick and compares him to a dying rat
before saying that she likes him as well
after arriving at one of the keremese
houses tengan is seen caring for his
wife hinatsuru she tells him to leave
her to go investigate the loud sounds
that were heard within the district but
before he can do so she apologizes to
him for failing to complete the mission
when she initially arrived at yoshiwara
hinatsuru was placed in the kyogoku
house to investigate she realized that
wada bahime was the demon but could not
make any hasty decisions in an attempt
to escape and avoid suspicion hinatsuru
drunk poison and pretended to fall ill
however she was gifted an obi by the
orient to spy on her and ultimately kill
her if she did anything suspicious
tengen comforts henatsuru and tells her
she did well during the mission
revealing the defeated obi in the
background he advises her to leave the
district as soon as the antidote takes
effect to which she agrees as they
embrace as tengen leaves the house and
heads back towards the battlefield he
tries to listen for the sounds of the
demon and hears the vibration coming
through an underground cavern he pulls
out his blades and uses his sound
breathing first form roar to slam onto
the ground causing a large explosion
which can be heard by in the
distance she questions tangero as to how
many demon slayers are in the district
but he refuses to tell her she tries to
strike a deal with him that if he
answers her question she will spare him
while simultaneously trying to
intimidate him he begins to discredit
his ability to perform the water
breathing compared to sakonji and geyu
atangido mentions that he needs to rely
on the hinukami kagura in order to land
powerful blows but he lacks the ability
to perform multiple strikes with her
tanjuro tries to regain his focus and
encourages himself that all of his
training should pay off he mentally
envisions keojiro's voice telling him to
keep his heart burning and manages to
perform the hinokami kagura raging sun
to block darki's obi daki notices the
change in his fighting style as tanjo
cuts off a large section of her obi as
she tries to analyze this change tanjo
suddenly bursts towards her he swings
his blade down using hinukami kagura
flame dance to try and decapitate her
but she narrowly avoids it as tanjaro
tries to attack her again gains
the upper hand and tries to decapitate
tangido with her obi however tangio
utilizes another hinokami kagura fake
rainbow to escape is left confused
trying to locate where tanjulo has
disappeared to but within seconds
tanjiro appears behind her and uses
hinokami kagura firewheel to attack her
once again tangido's blade makes contact
with the neck of badaki manages to
quickly deflect tangero's attack and
sends him flying into the ground he
tries to continue his attack however
he's left exhausted from his use of
hinokami kagura and has trouble getting
up as daki quickly approaches tanjido
manages to use the recovery breathing
technique to overcome his technique and
narrowly avoids darki's attack tanjuno
goes on the offensive and attacks
however her obi gets in the way
preventing him from defeating her
leaving him with no choice but to raise
his body temperature even higher
tangible recalls an interaction he had
with keo at the butterfly mansion she
begins to worry over tanjuro's
uncontrollable fever and tells him that
she needs to inform shinobu tanjuro
tries to reassure her that he's fine and
not to tell shinobu however kyo mentions
that his fever has been at 100.4 degrees
for over several days now and it could
mean that something is terribly wrong he
confesses to her that he has been
training with the hinokami kagura in
order to improve his skills and begs her
to hold on a bit before reporting to the
shinobu here reluctantly agrees but
tells him that she will only wait for a
birth
back in the battle against daki tanju
begins to gasp as the hinokami kagura
begins to take a toll on his body but he
refuses to lead up in order to protect
the people in the district he uses his
determination to promise that he won't
allow daki to take another life and
cause the people to go through the
sadness he and his comrades had to
experience
his breath fumes out from his mouth as
he prepares to attack dhaki yet again
flashing back to earlier at the ogimoto
house a member of staff frantically
approaches the other woman as she claims
to have seen a monster the other woman
are left confused at the woman's unusual
claims as she explains that she saw a
boar monster destroying the ceiling and
the floor elsewhere in the house in
oscar can be seen cackling as he
discovers a hole leading to the demon's
nest he proudly yells at the hole to
prepare itself before trying to dive in
head first after realizing that only his
head fits he takes it as a challenge and
begins to snap his body claiming that he
can dislocate all joints of his entire
body all the while frightening the life
out of his staff they seem to be
observing him while he's doing this he
manages to somehow slither through the
opening and travels down through the
tunnel until he reaches a main cavern
area once he arrives he discovers the
long trails of the obi draped throughout
the entire cavern as he takes a closer
look he can see multiple people being
held captive within the obi and
discovers zenitsu knocked out among them
as well anosuke becomes disgusted with
the worm like obi and begins his assault
against the obi by slicing sections of
it off while simultaneously assaulting
it with words the women who were held
captive begin to slip out from these
sections causing the ob to panic at the
situation around it the obi analyzes
inosuke's natural abilities and has
trouble formulating a plan however
darky's consciousness takes control as
she orders the obi to capture him alive
azinosuke prepares to slice another
section of the ob it suddenly becomes
more elastic and folds along inosuke's
blade before the obi can attack him
though inosuke gains the upper hand by
maneuvering to perform beast breathing
sixth fang palaside bite however the obi
manages to distract him the obi mentions
inosuke's failure at protecting the
individuals he's freed claiming that it
can just easily swallow them all up
whole again
it proceeds to move towards the
unconscious individuals however a kunai
flies out of nowhere causing the obi to
react two women appear holding kunai and
agree with anosuke's description of the
worm like obi and begin to attack it
they explained to inosuke that they are
there to help him and will protect the
others from the ob anoski reluctantly
agrees but then he asks them who they
are to which they reveal that they're
the tengan's missing wives suma and
makio
makio begins to scold sumer who sulks
after revealing that she was the first
one who was captured she also begins to
cry as she realizes that they can't help
everyone and are most likely going to
die the obi seems pleased by summer's
pessimistic attitude and questions who
should get eaten first but before it can
get the chance to attack zenetsu quickly
attacks the ob
amazed by his skill enosuke comments
that he probably shouldn't wake zenetsu
up and summa and makio question this
man's identity the ob is left amazed by
zenitsu's speed but tries to understand
the sounds it heard it specifically
mentions that there were two sounds like
thunder one came from zinetsu but when
the obi finally recognizes the source of
the second sound the ceiling explodes
and breaks down
suma looks up into the distance and a
silhouette can be seen from the
individual who's dropped down into the
hole tengan brandishes his blades as he
takes a deep breath and within seconds
slashes the obi within his vicinity
makio turns around and calls out to
tenkan who apologizes for taking too
long he then promises that things are
about to get real flashy going back to
makio as a young adult she lived the
lifestyle of a kunuichi and was often
taught to survive instead of trying to
accomplish the mission these ideals were
again reiterated into her mindset when
she married tengen
who would tell his wives to always
prioritize their lives and return to him
he would make sure to let them know that
he would take responsibility to protect
the public after protecting them mahia
would often question if his morals were
right or not however hinotsuru would
reassure her that wanting to live was
not immoral back in the cavern tengan
greets his wives by passing them on the
head and compliments that they've put in
great work inosuke calls out to the god
of festivals and gets mad at him for
allowing the obi to escape but tengan
loses his temper and defends his wives
saying that they save the people that
were trapped makio interrupts him to say
that they need to leave immediately
before things get worse he then quickly
instructs everyone to follow him
now up on the rooftop tengan sprints
towards the battlefield and inosuke and
zinitsu struggle to catch up with him in
the middle of the battle between daki
and tanjuro the oh becomes flying and
unexpectedly enters darkie's body
tanjuro realizes that the ob is entering
darky's main body and tries to attack
her but she quickly disappears she then
reappears on a nearby rooftop as her
hair turns white she squeals with
delight as she learns there's a hush era
within the district at that moment a
bystander discovers tanjudo acting
suspiciously on the street and tells him
to stop fighting in front of his shop
ducky overhears the man and becomes
enraged by his comment she lashes out a
flurry of attacks on the buildings
around her and ends up cutting off the
man's arm and the process she also
manages to kill other bystanders in
nearby houses destroying them all as
well tangido sees the bloodshed nearby
and tells the man to tie turnika around
his arm despite bleeding heavily himself
daki begins to walk away after
destroying the houses but tanjido tells
her that he will not allow her to get
away with this cockingly tells him
to stop speaking to her since an ugly
human's life has no value and he is just
another rotten corpse hearing this and
seeing the damage that she has caused
around him tangero's heart begins to
beat louder and louder and his eyes
start to fill with rage
tanjulo recalls a letter that was
addressed to him by shinjuro ringoku who
admits that he wronged him in the letter
he thanks him for mourning kyogido's
death as well as for befriending
sengioro and proceeds to express his
embarrassment for his behavior when they
first met
he explained that he was wallowing in
sorrow over the death of his wife and
incompetence as a hashira that he turned
to alcohol despite his lack of presence
as a father kiyojiro had proved himself
to be a better son he was managing to
become a how sharer even though shinjiro
had refused to continue teaching him
shinjuru writes in his letters that
tangier was gifted with a power and is
destined for greatness as seen from the
demon slayer mark he was born with
however tangiero clarifies that shinjuro
is wrong because he wasn't born with the
mark he recalls guessing the mark when
he was protecting his younger brother
from a falling brazier and then it
changed his appearance during the final
selection unlike his father who was born
with the mark sanjido simply acquired it
meaning he wasn't a chosen one
nonetheless
he refuses to back down
back in the fight as walks away
from tanjuro he quickly grabs her and
narrowly tries to cut her neck but she
manages to avoid the attack and move
away from him she loses her foot in the
process but her regeneration skills
allow her to develop a new one within
seconds tanjuno notices her regeneration
and asks daki why she steals people's
lives and ruins them his tone of voice
comes off as familiar tadaki as she
envisions a different swordsman before
her although she doesn't recognize the
swordsman realizes that she's
envisioning muzan's memories tangero
continues to question her reasoning and
taunts her with the fact that she was
once a human who endured hardships as
well proceeds to glorify the
privileges of being a demon seemingly
mocking the circumstances that humans
face her confidence grows as
believes that she is now untouchable due
to the fact that she has returned back
to her original form
she bids tangero farewell and begins to
think about going after the hashira
however tanjo utilizes the hinokami
kagura burning bones summer sun to burn
the obi blocking his path ducky is left
stunned by her wounds and inability to
regenerate to the point where she begins
to shake and is left to defend herself
from tangier's flurry of attacks he
closes in and swings his blade to
decapitate her but she continues to
resist as her neck transforms into an
obi refusing to be cut tangible's blade
begins struggling as it tries to cut
through darky's obi-like neck the
resisting cloth forces tangero to
abandon his attack and escape before
daki has the chance to fight back
however when he tries to recollect his
thoughts charges towards him and
tries to slash him tanjulo analyzes her
movements and has realised that he can
see her in slow motion giving him the
advantage as her wild obi attacks him
from multiple directions tanjuno manages
to pin them all in a single spot and
proceeds to charge at her while cutting
away the obi his flames burn the obi
away within seconds as he comes to a
close proximity to daki however just
when he's about to decapitate her tanju
envisions his sister hanako desperately
begging his brother to breathe in that
moment tangero loses his focus and
begins gasping for air after nearly
passing his physical limitations he
collapses onto the ground finally
feeling the pain that he has been
suppressing and his eyes begin to bleed
it is revealed that he has been acting
on hunger and has been using his life
force to surpass his limitations however
his sister was able to warn him before
he could sustain any life-threatening
damage daki glares down at tanjido and
berates him for his weaknesses as a
human she mocks his injuries and slowly
approaches him to deliver the final blow
before she can deliver the attack a leg
comes down and kicks behind
rupturing her head nisiko can be seen
boiling with rage as she stands between
tajido who's struggling to breathe on
the ground and nezuko recalls the
memories of when her family was
slaughtered on a snowy night and her
rage grows stronger as she prepares to
fight the upper ranked demon darky's
head and face begin to regenerate as she
glares holes into nezuko she recognizes
her as the demon muzan specifically had
told her about nezuko's face begins to
transform as her infinite anger begins
to push her forward leaving everyone
wondering what would happen in niziko's
case as she also gained the ability to
have no physical limitations
flashing back to just before when muzan
arrived at the kyogoku house to see daki
there he had told her to find the demon
who had escaped his grasp just like
tamiyo he identifies her as having a
hemp like pasu and kimono as well as a
checkerboard obi and tells daki that she
is his last hope to catch nezuko
flashing forward now in the present
promises that she will kill
neziko and lay her down at muzan's feet
as proof of this
nisiko faces and charges to once
again try to kick off darky's head
however is able to cut off
nezuko's leg using her obi while niziko
looks down at her bleeding thigh
uses the opportunity to knock her off
the roof and blast her into a nearby
building as the two demons are fighting
tangero falls unconscious and envisions
his brother takio in his dream takio
mentions how tanjuno and nezuko are very
alike when they're kind and angry and
goes on to recall an instance when he
saw naziko get angry he explains how
fearful he was when he saw her and was
worried about her lack of concern for
herself mentioning that within an
instant she could have lost everything
that she holds dear
back in the fight jumps down from
the rooftop and approaches neziko who's
trapped underneath a pile of rubble she
mocks her for being weak and a half
developed demon
daki continues to provoke her and
cockingly says that she will not fight
nezuko anymore and will simply leave her
trapped and expose her to the sunlight
instead however before can say
anything else neziko comes out from the
rubble and regenerates her leg in an
instant leaving stunned at her
abilities nezuko proceeds to
instantaneously regenerate her arm which
was cut off as well leaving
uneasy as she realizes that her
regenerative abilities are on par with
an upper-ranked demon nezuko's body
transforms as she breaks her bamboo
muzzle and a horn grows out the right
side of her forehead and her body also
becomes covered in ivy like demon crests
gets more intimidated by nezuko's
change in aura as she tries to defend
herself from one of her kicks
stressfully cutting it off with her ob
however before she can cut nezuko's head
is smashed to the ground by
nezuko's kick
is left shocked as niziko's leg
passes through her body pinning her onto
the ground she tries to make sense of
how niziko could attack her with the
legs she had just sliced off but then
realizes that nezuko had instantly
regenerated the leg within that moment
admitting that nezuko's regenerative
abilities are greater than her own
nesigo begins to become manic following
her transformation as tanjudo still
remains in his unconscious state takeo
desperately taps him on his back begging
for him to help he tells tangido to
please wake up and help niziko who isn't
acting like herself anymore forcing
tanjuro to awake with concern as this
happens remains pinned on the
ground and she tries to use her obi to
free herself from nezuko's hold her obi
effectively severes multiple limbs from
nezuko's body but before she gets the
chance to scoop them up nezuko's severed
hands grip onto her obi her limbs remain
connected by who unusually solidified
blood was some of the blood falling onto
in an instant dark is set on fire
by the blood causing her to scream out
in agony mizuko's limbs wind back to
reattach to her body and they
self-cauterize each cart she proceeds to
forcefully stomp down on darkie's head
causing it to erupt in flames
niziko continues to stomp multiple times
on her head before she forcefully kicks
through a nearby building and
into one behind it
as she follows to continue her
assault nezuko comes across an injured
woman who stares at nezuko with fear as
she tends to her bleeding wound
nesco falls into a trance and charges
into the home towards the woman as she
fails to suppress her hunger for blood
out of nowhere though tangero jumps on
top of neziko and uses his blade to act
as a muzzle in order to restrain her he
yells at her to fight the hunger and
encourages her to be strong but she
lashes out at him and scratches him on
the face trying to escape he apologizes
to her for making her fight after
smelling the blood that spilled from her
injuries he proceeds to reassure her
that her big brother is now there to
protect her and that she can now heal
herself nezuko manages to regain her
footing and she jumps through the
ceiling with tanjuro on her back causing
an intense amount of damage to happen to
the building as tanjulo struggles to
restrain his sister the walls of the
room are seemingly slashed as
barges into the room with her burned
face she is seen seething with anger as
she is forced to regenerate her burned
body and angrily approaches the siblings
tangerine becomes conflicted on what to
do as he realizes that there are
bystanders he needs to protect but he
also needs to defend dhaki's attacks
without releasing nezuko as tanjido
makes his decision to protect the public
tangent ozoe suddenly appears before him
and expresses his surprise in nezuko's
flashy demonization
tengu goes on to comically berate
tangido for speaking highly of nezuko's
ability to restrain herself back at the
ubishiki estate despite him struggling
to restrain her now
daki sees tengen and excitedly reacts to
ahashira arriving before her but is
quickly and chillingly told to shut her
tenkin tells her to scram and says that
she is too weak to be an upper ranked
demon all of a sudden darky's head which
had just been decapitated as tengan flew
past fell into her lap leaving her
completely stunned and simply confused
at what had just
transpired tangier was left shocked by
tengan's swift victory over daki but the
sound to shira reminds him that the
fight isn't over as his sister is still
out of control tangero struggles to
restrain her with tengan suggesting to
sing her a lullaby to put her to sleep
but at that moment nezuko regains her
footing and jumps out of another
building window taking her brother with
her again as they continue the struggle
realising his words aren't reaching her
tanju asks his mother in a dreamlike
state what he should do he then
remembers tengen's earlier advice to
sing nezuko a lullaby he begins to sing
her a song that their mother had sung in
the past and over a short period of time
his lullaby soon reaches her nezuko
remembers asking their mother about the
song when she was a child causing her to
break down in tears niziko comes to her
senses and changes from her advanced
demonized form into her regular
childlike state promptly falling asleep
tanjulo lets out a relieved sigh as he
successfully holds an isako in his lap
back in the house daki screams attengan
for cutting her head off and he responds
by telling her to die quietly the
enraged demon reminds him he had denied
her upper rank status which he affirms
but she proceeds to insist her status
much to his annoyance
to the hashera's astonishment daki
begins to throw attention and cry and he
notes that she's been taking far too
long for when she should have been
showing signs of dying by now
still throwing her tantrum daki calls
out to guatara to save her and a male
demon begins to emerge from her body
tengan senses the danger and attempts to
immediately attack the two but his
blades hit nothing by ear as the demon
disappears from his sight tengan wonders
why is still alive after being
beheaded as well as the presence of the
new demon who he comments is having a
great reaction speed guyotaro tells daki
to heal her burn complementing her good
looks and he then wounds tengan when he
attempts to try and attack them again
guatara complements tengan's attempt to
attack him as well as his success at
blocking his attack he reveals that he
was intending to kill tenkan with that
attack and prepares to take him on in a
battle
within the entertainment district there
are men known as goos or barkers who
work to attract customers to enter the
brothels guataru worked as one of these
men and eventually named himself using
the word goo
inside one of the brothels gyotato and
tengan are about to engage in combat but
before they do so gotaro begins to
analyze tengan's appearance he comments
about his nice face good skin and height
mentioning that he must attract a lot of
attention from woman guitar begins to
creepily scratch at his face until he
begins to bleed and voices his jealousy
over tengen's looks
in the corner of the room can be
seen crying as she whines at guitar to
kill the other demon slayers who burned
her as well
she proceeds to tell him that they
ganged up on her and she tried her
hardest to kill them causing guatara to
seethe with anger using two large
sickles he creates a flurry of large
arc-like slashes aiming them towards
tengen tanjulo can be seen carrying
niziko as he rushes to put her to safety
he looks up into the sky and sees the
sickles return back in the direction
that they came like a boomerang he
becomes concerned when he smells
tengen's blood and rushes to return to
help
at that moment inosuke and zinitsu can
be seen flinging towards tanjuro as they
awkwardly announce their arrival tanjo
quickly informs them to help tengan and
inosuke ensures him that he's going to
be real flashy before quickly leaving
tangido to put nezuko in her box back at
the parlor guataro seeds with jealousy
after witnessing how cool tenkan looks
by protecting the bystanders within the
home causing him to brag about his
appearance and marriage to the three
woman gurotaro pauses an astonishment
before furiously scratching his face
after hearing tengan's polygamy he
proceeds to use his blood demon art
flying bloodsicle to try and kill the
hashera but tengan manages to block it a
large explosion causes the floor beneath
tengan to give in and he manages to
escape by dropping down one floor
however guatara commands his sickles to
turn and they come straight for tengan
yet again by this point tengen had
realized guitar's abilities to change
the sickles and the directions that he
wants and tries to formulate a plan on
how we will try and defeat these
siblings he theorizes that in order to
kill the demons he would need to cut off
guataro's head instead of darky's head
and tries to test it out dengen grabs
three small balls and throws them into
the air he proceeds to aim for them and
precisely hits them to cause an
explosion within the brothel as the
brothel begins to crumble tenkin is seen
standing on the rubble as he admits it
won't be easy to defeat the demons he
looks at the large obi ball before him
and the siblings emerge unscathed as
they confidently proclaim that they
fight as one after successfully finding
the box and placing nezuko inside
tangier quickly tries to return to the
battlefield in order to assist uzui
while this happens at the battlefield
gyrotaro scouts as he mentions tenka's
supreme abilities calling him different
and talented compared to the other
hashiro he's killed his comments
somewhat irritate tenkan and he berates
him for thinking that he's talented
compared to the other people on the
planet calling him ignorance he grows
more and more angry as he recalls the
people that he's lost over the years
despite being called the chosen one by
guataro
after listening to him speak guru taro
grows irritated by the fact that he has
not died yet revealing that his poison
drenched sickle should have killed him
by now
tengan explains that he is a built up
resistance to poison as he was raised in
a shinobi household with nine siblings
but by the age of 15 seven of them had
already died his father was a cold
heartless individual who would regularly
force them to undergo intense training
and as a result his brother adopted the
same ruthlessness and cold-hearted
personality unable to understand that
type of mindset tenkin left his clan
alongside his wives and approached
kaguya yubishiki to become members of
the corpse kagaya had warned them it
would be hard to reject the values they
were raised in but openly welcomed them
and thanked tengan's family for deciding
to put their lives at the risk to
protect others in the present guatara
notices the deterioration in tenkan's
physical state and becomes gleeful when
he realizes that his poison is slowly
taking effect tinker proceeds to refute
his claims saying that he is still in
pristine condition and charges forward
to attack the siblings as they engage in
a battle tenkin manages to kick
away from guitar and releases numerous
dark bees which cause a cluster of
explosions by setting a distraction
tengen attempts to decapitate guataro
while only holding the tip of the end of
one of his blades but it is promptly
blocked by the demon as both sides
reassess the situation is left
whining as she pathetically reattaches
her head to her body once again guataro
comforts tengan about discovering the
method on how to defeat them but he
feigns his innocence pretending not to
notice despite tengen's discovery
guataro cockingly says they despite
knowing their weakness tinker will still
die from the poisoning since the demons
have the advantage in battle at that
moment zenitsu and enosuke arrive to
question the fidelity of guatara's claim
that they are going to win the two boys
flamboyantly announce their arrival to
the fight which confuses everyone at
their moment but then tanjudo drops down
from the ceiling above them and stands
between the injured tengan and the
demons preparing to fight makio and
sumer can be seen frantically trying to
evacuate the citizens of the district as
the battle resumes against the demons
gyotaro tries to discourage the three
new arrivals and manages to intimidate
tanjiro however tengen uzui comes up
behind them and proudly announces that
they are going to win as daki finishes
reattaching her head she loudly doubts
his words by saying that they can't win
since the hashera has been poisoned
unfazed tengan once again proudly
announces their intent to win and speaks
highly of the three boys looking back at
him tangible sees the persona of kyogiro
ringoku emitting from tengen as he
speaks which excites inosuke gyotoro and
daki get riled up and reveal that
they've eaten 15 and seven hashira
respectively and begin to attack the
group as daki attempts to attack tenkan
and tanjiro from behind zenitsu bursts
through the home within seconds to block
the attack and ernosuke follows up now
on the rooftop darki finally recognizes
zinitsu from the kyogoku house and he
demandingly commands her to apologize to
the girl whom he had found crying
earlier she mocks his speech by
revealing that the woman are treated
like merchandise within the district and
as the orion she was allowed to do what
she pleased with the other people since
she was the main breadwinner of the
house when she looks up at zunitsu a
third eye appears on darky's forehead
revealing that guitar can see them via
her eye now back at the brothel tangero
becomes intimidated by guatara's evil
aura but formulates a plan to counteract
his attacks and protect tengen however
the demon manages to rush towards
tanchiro within an instant and catch him
off guard narrowly passing him through
his jaw before he can do so tenkin grabs
a hold of tangero by the nape of his
clothes and throws him to safety before
engaging in the battle with guataro as
he crash lands and looks back to see the
two fighting tangero senses an ominous
object approaching them from above and
darky's obi can be seen crashing down on
all around them
on the rooftop can be heard
cackling as she admits she is now
displaying her full strength since
guatara is awake and allowing her to use
his advanced senses zenetsu and enosuke
can be seen covered in cuts and wounds
as they prepare to engage with in
battle guwataru disregards the claims
that tenkan made earlier of the boys
being suguko and tries to undermine
their capabilities as swordmen the four
demon slayers can be seen engaging in
battle with the two demons of the
entertainment district fighting
ferociously on the rooftop and inside
one of the brothels as the building
begins to collapse tengan uzui finds
himself getting cornered between two of
guatara's attacks however tangero jumps
in and manages to protect him from these
slashes tengen proceeds to use sound
breathing fifth form string performance
to try to corner guataro but daki's obi
interferes and protects her brother from
the attacks tengan begins to be pushed
back by the obi however tangent moves in
to cut the obi and tries to distract the
otado the hashira is left amazed at
tanjiru's endurance despite suffering a
serious shoulder wound and realises that
tanjunu had tied his sword to his hand
to prevent him from dropping it due to
his exhaustion
meanwhile on the rooftop zenitsu and
unosuke can be seen struggling as they
try to evade the attacks from darki's
obi the boys realize that dhaki is now
attacking them with the blood blades
used by guitar making it impossible for
them to approach her now that the
brothel has been destroyed tengan and
tanjiro are left to fight guatara and
the ob beneath the night sky on a nearby
rooftop henatsuru appears carrying a
large box filled with kunai darts and
proceeds to launch dozens of them down
below on guataro at first he is left
confused by the random attack but then
guitar uses his blood demon art rampant
art rampage to deflect them all away
from him guatara is left shocked though
when tenkan proceeds to attack him
despite getting pierced with the darts
he attempts to decapitate him with a
sickle however tenkan manages to evade
his attacks and successfully cuts off
his leg at that moment guatara is struck
on the neck by one of the kunai darts
and fails to regenerate his leg
realizing that the darts were coated
with a wisteria extract as his body
begins to go numb tangelo closes in on
him to try to decapitate guataro leaving
him seething with curiosity as the demon
slayers quickly gained the upper hand
the kunai darts which were utilized by
hinatsuru were revealed to be coated in
a poison which would generally paralyze
a demon for half a day or possibly even
immobilize a lower ranked demon she can
be seen on a nearby rooftop pleading for
the poison to work for even just a
moment as the demon slayers attempt to
decapitate guataru
however
at that moment guataru manages to
regenerate his legs and proceeds to
attack them at a close vicinity he uses
his blood demon art rotating circular
slashes flying blood scythes to emit
numerous blood slashes to attack them
before they can reach him uzui grabs a
hold of tanjuno again and throws him
back to protect him from the attack
within milliseconds tengan uses his
sound breathing form constant resounding
slashes to defect guatara's attack but
finds that he has disappeared from his
side to his horror he looks up to the
roof to see that guatara has managed to
capture hinatsuru and is about to kill
her tengan tries to save her however
darki's obi blocks him from reaching her
tenkin yells at guatara to stop as he
tries to push through tangido comes
close to the building and tries to use
this hinokami kagura to reach her
however his body refuses to listen to
him tanjulo quickly change his tactics
and uses a form of water breathing to
quickly save hanatsuru from kyotoro
realizing that he managed to save
hinasuru tanjiro decides to utilise both
water breathing as well as the hinokami
kagura in order to increase his
attacking power guataro is left
surprised by tanjuro's unexpected
maneuvers and chases at him at that
moment tengen comes behind guataro and
swings his blade akuotaro's neck while
openly yelling that he owes tanjido
nearby on a rooftop inosuke can see
tengen move in as he attempts to cut off
guatara's head his frustration grows as
they continue to evade darki's attacks
instead of move in to try and decapitate
her zenitsu calls out to winosuke and
explains that in order to defeat them
they need to make sure that their heads
aren't connected instead of trying to
decapitate the two simultaneously
anosuke stunned looks at zenetsu
absolutely amazed and calls him awesome
after seeing the difference in his
personality compared to his usual
demeanor meanwhile tangido assists
tenkan by also trying to swing his blade
down on guitar's neck however the demon
manages to use his sickles to hold both
of their attacks and attempts to absorb
their blades tengan uses his free arm to
use his second blade to pierce guataro
but his quick reflexes allow him to
catch the tip of the blade in his mouth
since he neck guillotaro is about to
unleash more blood blades tengan tells
tangier to hang in there as hinatsuru
yanks tanjiro away from them allowing
tengan to leap off the roof while
pulling the demon with him before he can
leap down to hell a voice can be heard
telling them to watch out as enosuke and
zine to crash onto the roof while
fighting the obi inosuke and zinetsu
asked tanjiro for help in order to
defeat daki and agrees asking that
they'll finish quickly in order to help
the tengen as well hinatsuru tells the
boys that she will hide quickly in order
to allow them to focus on the battle and
disappears as they face she gets
excited when tanjido joins their fight
and informs his comrades that they need
a fast attack in order to cut her neck
anosuke realizes that she has slowed
down and decides to go first to attack
as xenonsu agrees with tangido to
protect him from behind and oscar
proceeds to dash forward using beast
breathing 8th fang explosive rush was
inetsu and tangido use thunder breathing
first form thunderclap and flash
eight-fold and water-breathing third
form blowing dance respectively to
protect inosuke from the ob
begins to crack under the pressure as
inosuke closes in on her and manages to
draw both of his blades on either side
of her neck anoski bruises his heels
into the ground as he uses his beast
breathing sixth fang palisade bites to
effectively decapitate tangelo
smiles with joy as he witnesses inosuke
leap and catch darky's head in the air
rejoicing and successfully cutting off
her head inosuke claims that they have
to act fast and keep her head separated
from her body anosuke quickly tries to
escape with the head in order to prevent
her from reattaching it to her body he
tells the other boys not to worry about
him but to instead help tengan but
before he can even get to safety
uses his hair to put up resistance
he manages to stop her resistance though
but before he can get away guatara
appears behind him and impales him
through the chest tangero looks on in
horror as guataru grabs darki's head
while inosuke collapses to the floor he
then looks down onto the ground and is
once again horrified to see the tengen
laying bleeding and unresponsive on the
ground
zenetsu tries to warn tanjido of the
oncoming obi attack but before he can
escape the roof collapses beneath him
and tangero falls to the ground
seemingly buried beneath the rubble
as he falls unconscious he apologizes to
everyone and specifically neziko for
losing the battle
in his dream niziko can be seen telling
him to stop apologizing for any faults
in their lives or feeling unworthy she
reassures him that it isn't his fault
that their lives were ruined and tells
him that they'll work together to make a
better future for themselves
nezuko begins to cry as her body morphs
from her human form to her demon form as
she pleads for him to never apologize
for any regrets and tells him she
understands how he feels tangible
awakens from his dream and tries to
recollect his thoughts but before he
gets up guataro can be seen standing
over him questioning if he's still alive
guardato takes it upon himself to tell
tanjido that ignoski was pissed through
the heart
zenetsu was suffering and trapped
beneath the rubble and tengan's heart
had stopped due to the poison
he proceeds to refer to all of them as
pathetic and asks tanjiro how the demon
in the box is related to him and
responds by saying that she is his
youngest sister guatara begins to laugh
at tanjulo's pathetic attempt to protect
his younger sister and tells him he
should be using his hands before
proceeding to break his fingers as
tanjoru withers on the ground in pain
guataru proceeds to berate him for his
weaknesses and pulls him by his hair he
teases tangier and tells him to try to
decapitate him but instead of attacking
him he slaps his hand on a small bag and
hangs his head down a defeat believing
that he broke tangential spirit he
reveals his grand idea of offering
tangero the opportunity to become a
demon for the sake of his sister
tanjiro suddenly looks up into the sky
iguataru asks him if he's been trying to
hold back his tears but to his surprise
tanjiru responds that he had been
preparing for the moments his face gets
close to guatara's and tanjunu brings
his head down and headbutts him with a
great force momentarily stunning guataro
daki screams at him to get up but as his
legs falter he looks down to discover
that a kunai has been lodged into his
leg he realizes that when tangero had
looked down he had opened a bear given
to him by hinatsuru which contained
wisteria poison tanjunu manages to stand
back up while guitar remains paralyzed
and crouched before him tangier uses his
remaining strength to swing the blade
down onto his neck as he tries to force
the blade down and through tangero
envisions himself in guitar's place and
he thinks that if he were in this
situation he would want his comrade to
kill him before he could live as a demon
on a nearby rooftop can be seen
rushing to her feet at the sudden change
of events to try and help her brother
but before she can even get close to
them zenitsu manages to free himself
from the rubble he attacks her using
thunder breathing first form thunderclap
and flash to bring her attention to him
and then uses god speed to attack her
neck zenetsu pleads with his blade to
cut through her neck since he was given
the chance to escape the rubble and
attack her while guitaro was subdued
tanjiru continues to struggle to cut
through guatara's neck but before he can
do so guitar manages to emit his blood
blades to repel his sword tanjulo was
knocked off balance as guatara regains
his footing causing them to re-engage in
battle guataru gains the upper hand and
brings his sickle down on tangier's neck
however at that moment tengan regains
his consciousness and protects him from
the sickle despite being severely
poisoned and missing his left hand
denkin engages in the head-to-head
combat with guitar but remarking that
he's perfected the musical score
technique it is revealed that his
technique allows him to analyze
maneuvers of his opponents and read them
like notes on a piece of sheet music
however the poison had hindered his
attacking ability meaning that he can
only defend guataro's attacks guataro
manages to land a powerful attack to the
left side of tengan's face resulting in
the loss of his eye and proceeds to stab
tenkin tangero yells out to tenkan after
witnessing him get stabbed but tengan
orders him to ignore and jump tanjido
leaps into the air towards guatara and
attempts to decapitate him but is
brutally stabbed through the jaw by
guatara's sickle the demon begins
panicking as they gain the upper hand
and tries pulsating his poison to kill
tanjuro however tanjulo proceeds to
ensure through the pain and swings his
sword towards guatara
tangelo can be seen swinging his blade
down on guatara's neck despite the demon
sickle passing through his jaw his arm
strength isn't enough to slice through
his neck so he resorts to forcing his
entire body to push through ignoring the
pain
guitar notices the change in tangible
scar as he develops a demon slayer mark
and his eyes roll back in his head the
change in his demeanor proves to be too
great as tanjiro's blade cuts through
guatara's neck causing him to panic
meanwhile daki can be seen resisting
zinetsu's attempt to decapitate her she
tries to use the obi to kill zinetsu at
close range beninosuke unexpectedly
rushes up revealing that he protected
his heart from being stabbed by
rearranging all of his organs he also
reveals that the poison has no effect on
him at all since he was raised up in the
mountains before proceeding to assist
zinitsu by decapitating daki the three
boys let out a roar as they muster out
their strength to slice the demon's neck
after the long battle sinetsu and
inosuke manage to decapitate up on
the rooftop while tanjudo can be seen
decapitating guatara simultaneously on
the ground the heads fall onto the
ground and roll until they end up face
to face
as guataro's body falls onto the ground
tengan notices something being emitted
from it and becomes alarmed meanwhile
upon a nearby rooftop suma hinatsuru and
marchio have arrived to witness the end
of the battle
as makio begins to bicker with sumer
over her behavior hinatsuru notices
something as a miss down on the
battlefield she looks down to see
tangido is struggling to breathe as he
bleeds out from his jaw while trying to
slow down the poison tangelo looks over
at tengen who's sitting down in front of
him and yelling at him with a panicked
expression however tangero fails to
comprehend his sudden alarm as tengen
looks at him with horror
under the night sky nezuko can be seen
looking down as her brother with a
concerned expression
as tanjo begins to regain his
consciousness he looks around to see
these destroyed buildings around him
niziko nudges her brother as a way of
letting him know that she was the one
who saved him from the destruction
tangier attempts to get up to search for
the others but his legs give out from
beneath him and he collapses onto the
ground
he hears someone calling out to him in
the distance and recognizes the voice as
belonging to zenitsu and is unexpectedly
picked up and carried by nezuko the pair
move towards the source of the commotion
and discover zenitsu has awakened from
his slumber not remembering any of the
events that had just transpired he tells
tanchito that he can hear inosuke's
heartbeat getting weaker and weaker and
points to him laying unconscious nearby
the siblings rush over to him and
tangier attempts to wake up in oscar but
to his dismay he feels his heart getting
weaker tangita begins to panic and
thinks of exposing him to sunlight or
sending a crow to shinobu for help but
realizes that he doesn't have the time
for either options his tears begin to
swell up as inosuke lays dying before
him
but nezuko nonchalantly comes forward
and unexpectedly sets enosuke on fire
tangido looks amazed as he witnesses
enosuke's poisoned skin here right
before his eyes and his comrade suddenly
awakes to announce he's hungry the three
rejoice at the fact that he's okay and
embrace as tangido begins to sob
elsewhere on the battlefield zuma begins
to wail loudly pleading for tengan to
live after winning the battle her
co-wife makio begins to panic as she
realises the antidote they administered
is not working to remove the poison from
his body and hinatsuru begins to weep
realizing that he doesn't have much time
to live tengan begins to relay his final
words to his wives but is interrupted by
suma's loud whales makio becomes enraged
as soon as overreactive cries and begins
to pull by her hair and shove rocks into
her mouth to make her be quiet while
henatsuru tries to prevent them from
bickering in a comical fashion though
tenkan sits spectating at his wives
while they continue to bicker during his
final moments as he slips away he then
realizes that he can no longer move
speak or do anything due to the poison
but then everyone momentarily pauses
when neziko suddenly appears next to
tengan they proceed to stare at her as
she raises her hand and grabs him before
setting him on fire his wives look in
horror until sumer comically pulls
niziko away saying that it's too soon to
cremate him to this surprise tengan
begins to speak again and asks how it is
possible that the poison has been
removed from his body which brings
relief to his wives
tanjido subtly explains that nezuko's
blood demonard has somehow managed to
remove the poison from their bodies and
expresses his relief to know that tengan
is safe tengan tries to tell tanchiro to
rest if not he will die from his
injuries the tanjuno informs tengen that
he needs to confirm that the demons have
been defeated before he can rest the
siblings proceed throughout the rubble
in search of the demons heads and come
across a pool of blood
tangido pulls out an apparatus and
decides to collect the blood in order to
be studied
once the blood has been collected
tamiya's cat mysteriously appears before
tanjudo and he puts it in the box to be
delivered to tamiyo as the siblings
continue their search tangido smells the
scent of the demons and guides niziko
towards them when they arrive guitaro
and daki can be seen viciously arguing
over their defeat their heads begin to
disintegrate as they blame each other
for losing the battle with guitar
disregarding dhaki for being useless
retaliates by saying that someone
as ugly as guitaro cannot be considered
her relative which leaves tanjido
looking at them concerned about the
hurtful words they are spewing at each
other daki and guitaro continue arguing
as their heads begin to disintegrate she
starts chastising her brother for being
useless and questions if they are even
related guitar grows angry at her
comments and calls her a weakling even
regretting to protect her in the first
place he loses his temper and goes on to
spew hateful remarks such as mentioning
that his life would have been better off
without her and wishing that she'd have
never been born causing darky's eyes to
well up with tears tanjido intervenes
and covers guatara's mouth saying that
he doesn't mean what he is saying and
that they shouldn't spend their final
moments with each other arguing daki
begins to wail at tanjiru out of
frustration yelling at him to leave them
alone and stop lecturing them darky's
head reaches its last phases of its
disintegration as she cries out for her
brother to save her saying that she
doesn't want to die guitar hopelessly
watches as her head dissolves away while
still calling out to him before he
impulsively calls out to her by her
birth name ume
as he reaches his final moments guitar
recalls his past as a human born in the
kirimise to a prostitute mother before
she died from syphilis his mother tried
to kill him many times even after his
younger sister was born due to his
appearance and lack of hygiene the young
guy was bullied and detested by everyone
that he met
things began to change though after his
sister was born as her beauty dismissed
his inferiority complex and he uses
ugliness plus his newfound fighting
skills to become an efficient debt
collector however the good fortune would
not last long for the siblings when ume
turned 13 she blinded a samurai with a
comb and was viciously burned and buried
alive for her crime having been away on
his job at the time guitar returned to
find her barely alive in a hole and he
hugged her body as she cling to life he
cursed the gods to return his sister for
treating them cruelly before he is
attacked by the same samurai the samurai
slashes guataro from behind and a
manager there brazenly calls guatara a
nuisance and a brute for harassing the
locals of the district before expressing
their pissy at having lost ume as a
courtesan before the samurai could
finish him off guataro viciously kills
the manager and berates the samurai for
having a lavish lifestyle before
gruesomely killing him as well as
guatorre tried to find help for him and
his sister no one would help them due to
their reputation and circumstances he
trudges on through the street until he
ultimately collapses and bleeds out onto
the floor as the snow begins to fall the
siblings lay on the floor dying until
they are discovered by one of the upper
ranked demons who offers to turn them
into demons uetado unemantably proclaims
that he would become a demon again no
matter how many times that he is reborn
wanting to always bring fear as guataro
the debt collector guitar muses how dark
he could have been if he had raised her
differently before taking note of his
surroundings a younger looking
appeared behind him disgusted with their
current location and wondering where the
exit was the emaciated man ordered her
not to follow him anymore getting angry
when she would not comply
a tearful apologized for her
earlier cruel insults stating that it
was because she had not wanted to accept
that it was her fault that they had lost
when guotaro still refused to not let
her come with tackled him from
behind stubbornly refusing to ever let
go vowing to always be his little sister
no matter how often they are reborn and
finally accepting her company guitaro
carries his little sister into the fire
that awaits them
in the world of the living tanjiro and
niziko watches the last of the demon
siblings dissolve into the air
tangier wonders if they made up which
niziko affirms elsewhere obernai iguro
attempts to praise tengen for his defeat
of an upper rank 6 but is disappointed
to hear that he beat such a low ranking
member of the 12 kazuki as well as lost
his left arm and eye tengan states his
intention to retire as a shira but obani
refuses to accept this as there is
already a vacant hashera position and
their lower ranks of the demon corpse
keep on dying without improving
tengan disagrees with this last point
stating that tanjido is definitely
improving while obani is surprised that
he survived the fight
elsewhere kaguya yubashiki learns of the
group's victory and is elated but is
stricken by the complications of his
illness
he states that his victory will have
mass consequences enough to ensure
muzan's defeat within their generation
he then collapses into a continuous bout
of coughing over at the infinity castle
akasha ponder's howard summoning must
mean a member of the upper ranks has
been defeated akasa looks on with
displeasure as the benue demon plays her
instrument and is greeted by one of the
upper ranked colleagues gyoko the potted
demon asks him how he's been after 90
years and proclaims his insincere worry
over akasa being the slain upper rank
han tengu corrects his colleague as it
had actually been 113 years since they
had last been summoned and expresses his
concern over the oddity and the
unluckiness of the number ignoring them
akasa asks the by demon if muzin had
arrived the answer being no and then if
the upper rank one had arrived before
she can answer though doma places a hand
on a kaza's shoulder asking him to show
some concern for his well-being as well
as he did not wish to see any of his
precious buddies die gyoku and doma
exchange a small conversation about
gyoko's pot and doma's use of the pot
that gyoko had given him acaza demands
that doma remove his hand viciously
punching him when he does not
immediately do so quickly recovering
from the blow doma pleasantly asks if
kaza had gotten stronger since they last
met enraging the tattooed demon the biwa
demon finally relates that the upper
rank 1 had been the first to arrive
surprising akaza who spotted his silent
colleague kokoshibo noted that he was
present as was their master as each
upper rank reacted to the silent arrival
of their leader muzan noted that gyotaro
was dead doma apologized for kyataru's
failure wondering what punishment muzan
would give him but the ancient demon
declined all of his suggestions having
already anticipated the upper ranked
sixth defeat he further commented that
he did not expect anything from him
which doma questioned as he did not
believe that he had ever failed to live
up to his master's expectations but mooz
encountered by stating that the uber
yoshiki family had yet to be killed and
the blue spider lily had yet to be found
making him question why the upper ranks
even exist each of the upper ranks offer
some excuse for this failure save akaza
and gyoko the latter offers muzan some
information that he claims will get him
closer to achieving his goals swiftly
beheading the upper rank muzam berates
gyoko for speaking of change as he is
only looking for permanence he adds that
he is at the height of his displeasure
due to an upper rank being killed for
the first time in over 100 years further
berating kyoko for attempting to give
him unconfirmed information he demands
that the upper ranks serve him with
suicidal devotion from that moment on he
then orders gyoko to head over with han
tengu to see if he can confirm this
information
and then leaves
doma then approaches goku asking to join
him on his mission and then in an
instant has the upper portion of his
head completely destroyed by a kaza
akaza the upper rank 3 demon orders him
to get lost as muzan had not given him
any specific orders
akasa looks in disbelief as his arm is
sliced off by kokushibo doma attempts to
defend his subordinate but kokushibo
reprimands akaza for his actions as they
soil the relationships between the upper
ranks advising him to battle doma for
his spot as upper rank 2 instead if he
is truly bothered
after hearing the suggestion doma
interrupts and asserts that akaza
wouldn't be able to raise his rank given
how much more powerful he was despite
becoming a demon much later than him a
fact that likely contributed to acaz's
rage he continues on describing how he
allowed akaza to use violence on him as
a way to get along with him kokushibo
ignores doma and asks zakaza if he
understood what he meant
akaza confirms declaring that he would
definitely defeat him one day receiving
a word of good luck from his superior as
he leaves the fortress gomer tries to
start a conversation with akaza but he
ignores him as he exits gyoko then asks
nakime to send him and hantengu to their
next destination and which the bee were
demon complies to she additionally sends
doma back to his cold when he tries to
talk to her
after which he mopes over his
colleague's unfriendliness
somewhere else a man is seen sitting by
a house with another individual sumi
yoshi brings some tea and some food the
man thanks his friend for the
hospitality in which the letter
apologizes for his wife being asleep and
the child having to be babysat by a
guest he tells him not to worry about
the situation and that he shouldn't
continue receiving the meals for free
from his friend sumi yoshi denies this
revealing that his family was saved by
him and their lives were thanks to him
he also offers to pass down his guest's
tale as he didn't have any successes
even if his family were just simple coal
burners
sumiyoshi is gently turned down by his
friend as he states that his heritage
will find its way back itself and that
no matter what it will return
he then says that despite sumi yoshi
viewing him as powerful he was unable to
protect what was important to him and
had little worth
tangido internally begs the man to not
think of himself like that and cries as
he wakes up from the dream
heavily bandaged and hooked up to
multiple ivs
he tries to figure out where he is and
is suddenly interrupted by falling vaz
kano stands in shock in the doorway and
reveals that tanjuro had been
unconscious for two months tearfully
stating that she's glad he's awake
so well that finally brings us to the
very end of the entertainment district
arc from the one and only demon slayer
this arc really is something else out of
what i've read from kamek suno yiber
this arc is definitely my favorite which
is why i've decided to start here when
it comes to covering the entire demon
slayer story it's absolutely awesome to
see how much an improvement all three of
the young demon slayers have especially
zenitsu throughout this entire arc here
see now he was used as comedic relief
and the manga was absolutely hilarious
like when he gets left on the street by
tengan and we find him jamming out in
the middle of i can't remember what
house it is but with his shamason i
think that's just absolutely hilarious
and i love it compared to his like anime
version of zunitsu which i find almost
like
a little bit more annoying so i i love
the the comparison that we get from
anime to to manga zunitsu here i thought
i find him a lot better so hope the uh
the anime does take that kind of like
take with zenitsu and we do see a more
of like the funnier side of him this arc
this part of the manga takes place from
chapter 70 and goes all the way up to
chapter 99 if you guys are interested in
starting the story and reading like
throughout the manga and all that kind
of stuff so if you do want to start from
after this video then chapter 100 would
be like a good spot for you guys to
start from but if not like i do still
recommend that you guys read throughout
the entire arc just in case i've missed
like a thing here or there that you
might find there's like vital
information later on throughout the
entire story and uh i might have just
missed it if you have enjoyed this video
though then do feel free to hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with the algorithm and pushes
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing
people plus i put a bunch of work into
these uh like longer explained videos
especially this one over the last three
weeks i've put a ton of work into like
editing this video and getting it out
like on time and i keep having to push
things back but here it is now so if you
guys could uh hit that subscribe button
i would really really appreciate it i've
also got some merch if you guys are
interested which i will leave a link to
like it down below along with like my
patreon and all my like discord and that
kind of stuff if you guys do want to
join or look at all that kind of stuff
but anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all in a bit bye
[Music]
you